the spider-man no way home teaser
dropped late on the night of august 23rd
almost 24 hours after it leaked on
twitter it was a mad scramble to get the
leaked teaser off of social media and
the clips began disappearing from
timelines unfortunately plenty of people
still saw the teaser despite the efforts
to get rid of it marvel studios and sony
pictures did what they had to do and
dropped the beautiful full-length hd
teaser of no way home to the excitement
of fans who were awaiting the official
release after the leaked mess was
unleashed only the day prior in the
teaser we got to see peter parker
spending some quality time with mj as
the two deal with the reveal of
spider-man's identity to the world the
teaser also features doctor strange who
will play a significant role in the film
the sorcerer supreme grants peter a wish
and performs a spell that should make
the world forget who spider-man is of
course squeaky peter interrupts doctor
strange and it looks like the pair also
opens a pathway to the multiverse the
fallout from doctor strange's spell
leads to all-out chaos and the viewers
are subsequently treated to sneak peeks
of some of the movie's villains
for quite some time now rumors have
suggested that some significant villains
from former spider-man films would be
appearing in no way home alfred molina
surprisingly confirmed dr octopus would
be back and he showed up in a big way in
the teaser at the end of the lengthy
clip we see the villain's signature
robotic tentacles bust through asphalt
before the man himself appears out of a
smoke cloud in his trench coats and
sunglasses as he says
hello peter the dangerous spider-man 2
villain is the clearest and most present
threat in spider-man no way home but he
definitely isn't going to be the only
adversary for everyone's favorite
multiverse spider-man just before doc
ock appears viewers get a glimpse at a
weapon used by a notorious spidey
villain green goblin's pumpkin bomb
comes rolling down the street to the
beautiful familiar sound of a chaotic
chuckling
most fans of sam remy's early 2000s
spider-man trilogy will recognize this
as the voice of norman osborne played by
the great willem dafoe though we don't
see defoe's character outlets like
cbr.com have reported that this won't be
the case in the actual movie and green
goblin may actually be the main villain
of no way home the teaser proves that he
will quite definitely be in the film and
his considerable powers and larger than
life personality certainly make him a
valid big bad candidate for the entire
film it seems as though no way home is
building towards something a bit bigger
than just those two villains several
shots of lightning in the teaser trailer
drop a not so subtle hint at electro's
presence in no way home a villain made
famous by jamie foxx in the amazing
spider-man 2. in october 2020 the
hollywood reporter revealed that fox
would be reprising his role and the
lightning bolts in the trailer are the
perfect tease to his triumphant
restoration additionally there appears
to be a sand storm mixed in with some of
the lightning sequences which might very
well mean that thomas hayden church's
sandman from spider-man 3 is also back
for a rematch there's even a blink and
you'll miss a jump scare moment from
reese evens the lizard who appeared in
the amazing spider-man this fantastic
new teaser trailer pretty much confirms
that these five villains will be a part
of no way home and we suspect there's at
least one more coming as the sinister
six has long been rumored to be a part
of the film in the comics many villains
have played a role in the group over the
years so multiple characters could fill
that last spot the scorpion from
spider-man homecoming is a potential
sixth member and of course there's the
main big bad from homecoming still
flying around so to speak michael
keaton's vulture is showing up in
morbius so there's that character's
potential for no way home you can catch
spider-man no way home when it lands in
theaters on december 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]